hi i'm schloss fraser a second year
computational neuroscience phd student
at the donders institute in the
netherlands and today i want to talk to
you about a few neuroscience books that
i've read over the last few weeks such
that i hopefully can inspire you for
your to be read list and give you some
inspiration for the next book to read so
let's dive straight into it so the first
book is the nocturnal brain and did i
pick this book for its cover maybe but
it's a really beautiful cover so it's
the nightmare neuroscience and the
secret world of sleep by guy elijah
lysiner this book was so fun if you're a
fan of oliver sacks and his way of
writing i think you really enjoy this
book so guys elijah is this psychiatrist
and he works with sleeping disorders or
at the sleep institute so he talks about
different patients that he had over the
years and really talks about their
experience and then alongside that he
kind of explains where the disorders
come from or what the current theories
are surrounding certain sleep disorders
and i think this is a really intuitive
and nice way to explain neuroscience so
you take a case of a certain patient and
really walk people through what their
problems are and how they experience
this because i think in modern
neuroscience we sometimes leave out the
subjective experience of the patient and
everything has to be very scientific and
very objective but in the end we need to
remind ourselves that we are working
patients that have real troubles and
subjective experiences to me are even
more important than the objective
measurements we take of the people so in
general i find it really interesting
that there's a super strong link between
sleeping disorders and certain
psychiatric disorders we see it in the
lab as well that usually when people get
depressed before their depression onset
they already show troubles in their
sleeping patterns and it isn't exactly
clear which way it works is it because
you are depressed that you don't sleep
enough or is it because you don't sleep
enough that you get depressed we now
think that it's kind of both ways most
likely and also for example in
schizophrenia it's very common that
before an onset of a psychotic episode
people are usually not sleeping for a
really long time and you can for example
see this really well in the movie the
machinist if you haven't watched it
watch it it's so good so in the
machinist trevor an insomniac operator
who has not slept for months experiences
unusual occurrences at home and work a
strange man follows him everywhere but
no one else seems to notice him so this
movie i enjoy it a lot it really takes
you to this very creepy occurrence of a
man slowly going towards insanity and he
also talks about another syndrome in his
book the sleeping beauty syndrome which
i found really interesting i never heard
of it before so the official name is the
kleiner-levin syndrome also called the
sleeping beauty syndrome and it's a rare
disorder predominantly reported in
adolescent meals characterized by
recurrent episodes of hypersomnia so
yeah i think this in general is a really
fun book to read i won't go over all the
patience but just to give you an idea so
he has in the still of the night disney
was right rumblings the sleep talking
bus driver weak with laughter buzzing
bees so all of these are about different
sleeping disorders and i think you can
learn a lot so yeah i recommend on this
one then the second book i re read was
by lisa feldman barrett also discover
so beautiful but anyways um it's called
lessons about your brain or seven and a
half lessons about the brain and i
mostly picked up this book because her
previous book i enjoyed a lot it's
called how emotions are made for me this
was a really interesting book about a
lot of topics that i personally haven't
researched that much so i found it
really interesting to read but i have to
say this book was a little bit different
it's a lot more focused on people that
don't study neuroscience or haven't
don't have any experience with
neuroscience so it's a lot of lessons
that are in my regard already things
that are established for quite some time
but i think if you're very novice in
neuroscience or you never read anything
about neuroscience this is a really good
book to start because it's extremely
easily written and also the things she
talks about are not super hard to grasp
so i personally really like chapter five
and that your brain secretly works with
other brains so for example she says
part of being a social species it turns
out is that we regulate one another's
body budgets the ways in which our
brains manage the bodily resources we
use every day so one of lisa feldman's
theories is that one of the key
components of our brains is to manage
our body budgets and this is kind of
this alliostasis and aninaliostasis is
defined as the process of maintaining
homeostasis through the adaptive change
of the organism's internal environment
to meet perceived and anticipated
demands so i find this really
interesting that she correlates this
with other brains i think this is a part
of research a lot of us neglect that
usually we see the brain in the fat so
we only look at the individual and their
brain and we actually don't look that
much with brains surrounding these
people whereas we know that brains kind
of synchronize in certain matters so for
example you have these mirror neurons
and also with babies and mothers for
example this is very strongly seen that
brains kind of synchronize but it also
happens on a smaller scale that the
people you surround yourself influence
directly your brain and your behavior
and i think in the next few years we
will see this a lot more that we don't
only try to analyze people's brains
individually but also try to connect
them to other brains and actually see
how the patterns link between different
brains then the third book i read was
range by david epstein this is more a
popular neuroscience book i would say or
popular psychology but i personally
enjoy reading these in between other
more serious books or whatever so i
really liked his idea because it goes a
little bit against some of the advice we
nowadays get so he says to not
specialize really early or to focus on a
field really early but actually to try
to get range so the core idea of his
book is that specialization hampers our
ability to actually thrive in really
difficult environments one of the first
things he starts with is the difference
between a kind and a wicked learning
environment and a kind learning
environment is an environment where the
rules are really clear and where they
usually don't change over time so for
example you can think of a chess game or
the game go or poker for example and
usually these are environments where ai
systems currently do really well so
you've probably heard of ai systems
beating the chess champions or beating
go champions and this is easy
environments to learn with reinforcement
learning but what he actually thinks is
more relevant for us humans at the
moment are these wicked e-cosm
environments so wicked environments are
environments where some of the
information is hidden or it could even
be that if there's some kind of reward
or reward is delayed and also sometimes
the feedback you get is false or not
positive towards the final goal so in
general wicked environments are more
difficult environments so you can think
of the political climate but also at
university or just in general daily
living or daily human behavior is way
more a wicked environment than a kind
environment and he then gives some tips
or some tricks and different types of
stories on how to thrive in these types
of wicked environments because people
usually give advice for kind environment
so they say just specialize on this one
thing but nowadays we see actually that
hyper specialization can kind of hamper
your growth so one of the things he says
is to flirt with your future selves and
i really love this idea it kind of
reminded me of a video i saw called
intellectually promiscuous which is one
of the best two phrases combined by
ahmed el gandur i hope i pronounced that
right by ahmed al-gandu and ahmed el
gandum but also david epstein they kind
of say that instead of really seeing
yourself as one fixed attacky in time
try to think of different versions of
yourself or different possible futures
for yourself so instead of currently i'm
a researcher right but instead of saying
i'm a researcher for the rest of my time
maybe i could also be a teacher or right
now a youtuber or instead of thinking
i'm a physicist which i used to be i
could also just think of myself as a
broader scientist and kind of get
information from all science fields and
i think this idea of flirting with your
possible future selves is really fun and
really interesting and then one of the
big advices in his books so the third
thing is kind of that he says to study
from different fields and i really see
this in my field so my field is
neuroscience and i think a lot of people
think that when you study neuroscience
you should have a bachelor for example
in psychology or something medical but
actually the people in neuroscience in
my team they come from all backgrounds
so they come from mathematics
physics computer science biology also
psychology and the medical field and all
of these fields together allow us to
understand the complex organ that is our
brain but if you just studied
neuroscience and you only had people
from neuroscience we would have never
made any progress and for example one of
the biggest things we have right now our
neural networks and neural networks were
inspired by neuroscience and then
applied to ai so i think if you are
right now a student i think it's good to
just try to learn from a lot of fields
and not to really focus on one field and
make yourself really narrow so yeah
these are three books i read these last
few weeks and i really enjoyed them so
if you have some books that you would
recommend for me to read next i would
love to hear that so put that down in
the comments below and otherwise see you
next week bye